elle devait démarrer sa campagne de
vaccination ce mardi 16 mars
mais les annonces du président de la
république emmanuel macron hier sur la
suspension du vaccin contre le coc vite
astrazeneca a reporté le démarrage pour
la pharmacie de l'espace saint quentin à
montigny le bretonneux la suspension de
l'utilisation du vaccin de 24 heures
donc si retard doit être doit être plys
ce sera un retard de 24 heures donc en
soi ont pu après ça fait un an qu'on est
dans cette situation donc c'est pas 24
heures qui vont changer grand chose
le problème c'est là la perte de
confiance que l'on va avoir vis-à-vis de
ce vaccin qui n'a pas n'a déjà pas bonne
presse
cette suspension fait suite à un certain
nombre de cas de caillots sanguins chez
des personnes ayant reçu le vaccin en
europe
l'elysée attend l'avis de l'agencé
européenne des médicaments pour remettre
l'astra et n'est qu'à sur le marché mais
pour romain souk et le problème c'est
aussi l'approvisionnement
on avait jusqu'à hier une centaine de
demandes par jour de deux personnes dans
la cible vaccinale pour pour se faire
vacciner en pharmacie avec un flacons de
dix doses on va pas très loin donc ça ne
cause plus de problèmes qu'autre chose
l'officine est aussi confronté à un
autre problème logistique la commande de
vaccins pour les médecins généralistes
en tant que pharmacie référente elle
doit alimenter une vingtaine de
praticiens pour attribuer les flacons on
doit se connecter sur un portail dédié
du lundi au mercredi
recommandée pour chaque médecin le
vaccin pour la semaine d'après avertir
les médecins qu'on a reçues c'est ces
fameux vaccin ça nous demande du temps
d'organisation du temps qu'on n'a pas
forcément pour le moment ces problèmes
tout comme la campagne de vaccination
sont suspendus la décision de l'agencé
européenne des médicaments est attendu
pour ce jeudi